this is not a tutorial this there's a
whole bunch of packages here I'm gonna
give you like a super brief example of
what each one does the vote really is to
help you choose the tool that is the
right thing for you to use in your work
before I start I want to I want to point
out one thing to distinguish my personal
recommendations which I plan to give you
some of I've formatted my personal
recommendation slides like this there's
a little speech bubble in the corner
that way you can know what is my opinion
and distinguish it from the real sort of
factual information which I hope is
mostly correct so that's a grain of salt
so take one of those when you see a
speech bubble so to help you decide
whether you want to take my advice I'll
just tell you a little bit about Who I
am I've been writing code for a long
time I think I still have my first
Python scripts it was it ran in Python
1.4 I used to work in physics now I work
in finance at Tudor Investment
Corporation in physics I wrote a ton of
Python data analysis code in finance I
still write a ton of Python data
analysis code a lot of it involves dates
and times this is useful in science
useful in finance useful in water places
as you may imagine my github is lx8
samuel if you go there you will find a
lot of half-finished projects that
you've never heard of that are
languishing so you have nothing else to
do so before we launch it to the
specific packages let's start with some
preliminaries such as some basic
concepts so what is time I'm not gonna
get super philosophical here but I think
for this for the purposes of this talk
we can think of time as it's kind of
like space except it has one coordinate
instead of three it's pretty simple you
know it's kind of this line and it
numbers and time kind of grow
monotonically it's a it's a fairly
straightforward concept it's actually
easier than space and in computer
programs I think what we're usually
interested in is recording the exact
instant when something occurred there
are a lot of different things you do in
time with time but I think this is the
most common application that's probably
90% of what you care about something
happens like a log line was recorded
where the user performs an action or a
transaction occurred or something like
that you want to record when this
happened
so you can kind of thing
about it and process it later now humans
of course have to go in and complicate
this the situation it's a very simple
concept but humans make it very
complicated so one way we do this is
that we divide time into into these
roughly 24 hours fans called days which
kind of correspond to the rotation of
the earth and then we specify time as a
date which is some coordinate in this
count of 24 hour days and then once we
know which day we're talking about we
talk about the time of day which is
starting from the beginning of the day
which we call midnight traditionally we
count some additional amounts of time
elapsed so we kind of have this double
hierarchy of coordinate systems but even
though the days and times we have this
completely bizarre coordinate system
every si has kind of cleaned everything
else up but with time we're stuck with
years twelve months to a year 27 to 30
days a month 23 to 25 hours a day 60
minutes to an hour and then 60 seconds
60 seconds to a minute so this is very
obscure a time system which
unfortunately we all learned in
kindergarten and this is really the only
natural way we as humans think about
time and then to complicate things even
further we don't even agree on when the
day starts so each government is
entitled as a government to slice up its
territories into time zones here's a map
this probably not even current so just
took a random way off google image
search so you know each government can
go and slice up its territories into
these time zones within each time zone
we agreed to set our clocks forward or
backwards from some hypothetical time
zone which we call UTC by some amount so
then all the times in all of the clocks
in the time zone are set the same offset
from UTC but that offset isn't even
stable throughout the year so we have
daylight savings time when all of the
the UTC offset shifts for a particular
zone forwards or backwards and then to
make things even worse governments are
at their liberty to change the time
zones anytime they want which they do so
it's not even a it's not even consistent
over history so this is really these are
the problems that we have to deal with
time time itself is not super
complicated but with dealing with all
the nonsense that humans have layered on
top of it is really what most of
time processing code is about
unfortunately so time zones fortunately
the selfless souls that I am a maintain
a database of time zone data that that
lists all of the different time zones
their historical current and projected
future offsets from UTC as a function of
time this is often called the Olsen
database you may have heard that term on
most Linux systems and Mac OS it's
installed in a directory called user
user share zone info if you've never
looked at this before or CD there and
poke around there's a bunch of files for
different time zones and symlinks as
well that contain contain these data
sets and windows it's stuffed in a DLL
I'm not a Windows guy but this is what I
tracked out it's it's a little bit
harder to look at the time zones in the
Olsen database have geographical names
we are right now and one called America
/ New York they're named generally after
a continent in a city a major city and
the time zone so right now New York
happens to the UTC minus 5 hours because
it's winter time in summertime as you
probably know we're on daylight savings
time and that's UTC minus 4 hours but I
want to point out that UTC minus 5 is
not the same thing as American New York
which is also not the same thing as us
Eastern for example there is a time zone
called
America Bogota that is also UTC minus 5
and in fact they are UTC minus 5 all
year long
whereas we switch between UTC minus 4
and UTC minus 5 because they choose not
to on our daylight savings time so I'm
just saying I'm just kind of laying the
groundwork here of all the kind of
complications that that the software is
supposed to do to motivate it now we
have countless variations on how to
format dates and times I just picked a
few random ones here you can have times
days and times with or without the UTC
offset you can update slashes colons
commas all the punctuation you can
imagine some people put the Year first
some people the month first some people
with the day first you can have names of
months numbers of months abbreviated
names of months Dave's of weeks predated
Dave's of weeks and of course it doesn't
have to be in English right every
language has its own conventions and
names for all of these things
this is super fun if you have to work
with internationalized user interfaces
anyone here do UI internationalize you
got alright so I hope you never have to
do this on four computers there is a
standard family of formats called ISO
8601 it's the long boring spec that
tells you all the different ways you
should format daytime's
for use in computer programs there's not
for human users this is for computer
readable stringify dates and times but
ISO 8601 is actually as a family of
formats there is on top of that at RFC
3339 which specifies a specific format
or may be a much smaller family of
formats which is recommended for
internet protocols and those look like
this ones at the bottom there's a
there's a date separated by dashes a
capital T at the time and then UTC
offset at the end sometimes actually
instead of plus zero zero colon zero
zero you'll just see a Z Z stands for
Zulu time this is an army time old
convention and that also indicates the
UTC time zone so if you see a time zone
ending with Z that means that is a UTC
time stamp so that brings me to my first
recommendation which is to use the RFC
3339
time format in all of your api s and in
your data files if it's for a
non-technical human consumption in the
user interface by all means
internationalize it to whatever the
users want but when you're working with
code that's mainly for developers or for
the computer itself use the use that
standard time stamp your code will be
more compatible your data files will be
easier to read in other systems and you
will save yourself a lot of
implementation business ok I haven't
said anything about Python yet so let's
go on to Python now so I kind of spent a
long time serving all a lot of the
different packages out there and I found
forest general categories of ways that
people represent dates and times in
Python the first one is not even a bunch
of packages it's just using built-in
types so strings and integers you've
probably all done this before at some
point the second one is the standard
library day time package so that ships
with Python it's there as soon as you
install Python you don't have to install
anything else but there are also a sort
of ecosystem of helper packages that are
used with day time to fill in some of it
speech
future gaps so that's the second
category the third one is there are
derivatives of the date/time library
people have taken the day time library
as the starting point and use it to
implement sort of richer or easier to
use day time libraries and I'll talk
about some of those and then finally
there are representations for dates and
times that are specific to large
datasets so if you have rather than a
single time or single date you have a
column in a table or in a large data set
there are representations that people
use for those as well so I'm gonna go
into each of these first primitive types
I won't belabor this too much but a
simple way to obviously specify a time
or date is a string so there's some of
the string of fide format you can take
my advice and use RFC 3339 or you can
use something else another option is
that you see often for dates people will
take the integer components of the date
and encode them in one single integer
how many of you have written code like
this at some point come on admit it I've
written it at least 20 times in my life
easily so the super convenient end and
these have one huge feature and that is
every single system can store string and
can store an integer so you have a CSV
file you have adjacent file you have
some ancient database whatever your
system is you can stuff this in and
that's that's a super useful thing you
don't have to worry about what kind of
dates as this board was its resolution
stuff like that you just drop the string
in there you'll get it back so that's
that's fantastic but if you have to do
any operations at all on these times
you're completely on your own right you
have to implement everything from
scratch you want to know what the year
is you got to fish it out you want to
know what the next date is you have to
know how calendars work right so you
have absolutely no operations handed to
you if you use these formats so my
recommendation is to avoid these except
for very simple formats like CSV and
Jason where you have to write they don't
provide date types they only provide
strings or I guess jason has a few other
things but Bates sometimes are not among
them so in these cases put a string of
five date in but in other cases I I
strongly urge you against using string a
fight and particularly integer encoded
that sometimes in your applications
because as soon as you need to do any
operations at all you're stuck and you
end up reinvent
there's another type of integer
representation actually that are
slightly better these are tic
representations so in a taste
representation you choose a starting
time which are is called for whatever
reason an epoch and then you choose a
time unit let's say a second and you
just count ticks starting from that
epoch or negative if you want to use
negative integers so in UNIX and in
Python traditionally we use UTC midnight
on January 1st 1970 as the epoch the
starting point and then we count seconds
forward so this has a this has a very
simple physical interpretation is very
clear is very simple the very the
simplest Python date API actually is
this one it's the time time function and
this returns your computer system clock
in seconds since midnight January 1st
1970 UTC so if you know this
representation was good enough this
would be my last slide and this top
would be over and the world would
actually probably be a happier place but
this is not the case unfortunately so
the sort of thing that most people reach
for first is the day time package in the
Python standard library so if you import
day time you already have a lot of
functionality in there this solves many
of our problems for us
day time stores that provides a time
type which it calls a date time so that
both the module and one of the types in
it are called date time so just a
disambiguate in the talk if it's in if
it's in mono space then it's the class
the type name if it's in regular font
then it's Venice the packaging so the
date time type in the date time package
stores a time it stores a year month day
hour minute second microsecond
components under the hood so there's a
there's a little D data structure which
stores these components in it but it
provides all the operation not all
provides many of the operations that you
would want on top of it because it
stores microsecond pieces the resolution
is one microsecond which may or may not
be enough for you people work in finance
may not find this adequate some
technical users may not find this
adequate either but for things like
Apache logs or whatever it's probably
enough it also provides two flavors of
times and this is an important
distinction this is terminology that I
think is Python specific but is very
widely used
there are the notion of naive date times
which do not carry a time zone they only
carry a date and a time time of day and
then there are localized time zones
which contain a date time of day as well
as the time zone and I just want to
point out a naive date time does not
actually specify the instant when
something happened if I tell you this
happened at noon on November 11th 2017
you don't know when it happened because
I might be talking about New York might
be talking about Tokyo I might be
talking about London am I talking about
Timbuktu you don't know right you need
either a time zone or a UTC offset to
turn that date and time into an actual
physical time when something occurred
but sometimes in some and some software
that that that air that time zone or
that UTC offset is implicit so it's it
can get tricky one thing I will point
out about daytime is even though it
stores all the components for each day
time the class is imported is
implemented in C and is actually rather
efficient it's it's actually
surprisingly well fast given how it
operates which I think I found
surprising when I have benchmarked it
here's some quick examples of some
things the date/time library will do you
can call for instance UTC now you get
back the UTC current current date and
time you can fish out components dot
month a day you can split it into a date
and a time and then there's also parsing
and formatting which is based if you've
worked and see there's this there's
there see library functions called stir
F time and store P time that have been
around forever and they have these like
percent m % y % d % H format codes that
are used to specify how you parse in a
date/time string or format one back so
here's an example of that it is nicely
integrated into Python standard
formatting system so for instance you
can see in the second line from the
bottom you can put those from format
codes directly into the curly braces in
a string format so that's a super useful
feature if you're formatting these but
these percent eight percent and things
take a while to get used to kinda have
to go stare at the table find the one
you're looking for and after five years
of writing this code you'll finally
remember them
so my advice is to represent to date use
a date object so date time gives you a
day time which is a date and a time it
gives you a time of day which it calls
time and it gives you a date object and
use the correct one for the job if
you're only talking about a date don't
don't put in a midnight time for a date
because a date a day and a tie an
instant are not the same thing a date
time and a date are not the same thing
the date represents a geographically
specific roughly 24-hour period whereas
in a date time represents an instant
hopefully a localized one so you know
which one you're talking about some
shortcomings of day time it has some
limitations one one major one is it
provides a timezone API but it doesn't
actually provide any time zones so
there's a there's something called TZ
info which is an interface for what time
zone information should look like but
there no actual time zones in day time
the API also is not always the most most
convenient if you work with it a lot
you'll kind of learn a way you learn
your way around its its idiosyncrasies
but it takes a little while to get used
to it and to implement some more
complicated operations and finally I
would say that the one microsecond
resolution is actually showstopper for
some implement is for some applications
rather so you have to decide whether one
microsecond is an adequate resolution
for you so one way people get around
this is they build libraries around the
day time package so one of them well
known you probably have used it it's
called pi TZ this contains its own copy
of the Olson database so you actually
have to update it regularly to make sure
you pick up the latest timezone data
even if the interface doesn't change and
it implements the TZ info interface
using this data set so here's an example
of how you use it one thing you have to
be very careful about is that with PI TZ
you have to call this PI T's this time
zone dot localized method on your naive
date times to turn them into into
localized date times that is the correct
way of converting a naive day time to a
localized day time if you just try to
stuff the timezone object into the TZ
field you will get the wrong results and
this has screwed up lots of people many
times so hit this code and kind of study
it if you plan to use by TZ
my recommendation is in your code to use
explicitly localized UTC date times as
much as possible if you use if you use
their time and pie cheesy so my my
personal version of now looks like this
I called a time you TC now and I
immediately will localize it with PI TZ
UTC so you look at now the return value
from that it says TZ info equals you to
see at the end I know this is a UTC
daytime any other code that tries to
manipulate it is forced to recognize
this as a UTC data another option to use
with daytime as a package called date
util has been around for a long time it
also contains a time zone implementation
in date utility Z and it and it not only
carries the entire list and database
with it but it will also use the one
installed on your system in the old days
that used to be a bad idea because a lot
of older especially Linux distributions
did not have up-to-date timezone
databases but I think this mostly has
been resolved in in modern distribution
so chances are like my laptop has one
that's about two months out of date my
Linux computer at home of one to 17 is
also up-to-date so this is not not
really an issue
one other thing date utility provides
which is pretty nice as convenient
parsing so you'll notice that on this
parse line at the bottom I handed it
some random date time format that I
happen to have and I didn't have to tell
it what the format was I kind of looked
at the string and decided oh yeah it
looks like a date up front
November is 11 and it produced the
correct date time out of it so and and
it even localized so you see that Tzu to
see it then so that's a useful feature
there's some other stuff in date util
I'm not talking about calendars and
recurrence relations at all in this talk
but if you need that stuff a date you
date util is a place to look I'm not
gonna go into that here another thing is
it has an Easter calculation if you want
to be a time nerd look up the Wikipedia
article on computers which is a multi
century long mathematical history of
ways to calculate the date of Easter
which for some reason is complicated
so it's kind of interesting if you have
a Saturday afternoon to waste be able is
an internationalization library that has
data time support so if you need your
day times in Chinese this is one way to
do it it has a fairly wide range of
languages
it also supports if you don't like the %
y % and m % D stuff it supports a more
sort of Jodha style date/time formatting
where you put mm mm and YY YY and things
like that so if you prefer that you can
consider using babel but the main
advantage is that it knows lots of
languages one last one I want to
actually second the last one I want to
mention to go with daytime is this
package called you daytime which is
basically an acceleration library for a
handful of operations inside day time
particularly for parsing and formatting
strings so if you for instance want our
writing log files really really fast and
all you need to do is get a string if
I'd UTC daytime as a time for a
timestamp to go in your log files you
can consider using you date time it's
it's substantially faster than the core
date/time implementation I think this
doesn't run on Windows I think it's
POSIX on and finally to go a date time
there's a there's a nice package called
human eyes this is you know like when
you get pushed and you'll go on github
and it says oh yeah you know Alex Samuel
committed this four minutes ago right it
kind of knows it knows when this code
was committed and knows the current time
and it's writes a sort of human friendly
indication and then if was yesterday it
says yesterday and I may say a week ago
or two months ago that's what human eyes
does basically so you can see here I
took the current time I slept for 10
seconds and I asked you and eyes to
format it and it said 10 seconds ago
right stuff 20 seconds would have been
said 20 seconds that's that's a that's a
fun thing for user interfaces
now onto derivatives of daytime there
have been several attempts to to improve
day time either by wrapping it or
Estonia so let me present a few of these
one that's been around for a while it's
called DeLorean so this wraps daytime
daytime in a pure Python rapper called
DeLorean and it also integrates PI these
PI TZ Babel and human are
it provides some convenience methods so
one really nice thing about is you don't
have to instantiate your time zones
explicitly you can just pass in a time
zone name and it figures out how to
fetch the time zone for you and it has
some stuff like trunk a as I said it
integrates human eyes one thing I don't
like about it is it provides no date and
time classes it only has a date/time
class and the API sort of feels
inconsistent to me it doesn't for
instance participate in the normal
Python string formatting you have to use
the specialized format date/time method
rather than normal format another option
is arrow which also wraps daytime
daytime in a pure Python class as with
DeLorean you can pass on time zone names
it integrates state util dot easy four
times in information but also it does
not provide date and time classes it
only provides the date time type but it
does have some nice well-designed
convenience methods you can convert a
lot of things very easily to an arrow
instance so here I passed in epic
seconds that one five one one seven and
so forth and immediately figured out
what what this is
it has methods for instance to replace
components to shift forward or backward
a month a day an hour or whatever you
need and it actually also has its own
implementation of customized day time
formatting in about 50 languages this is
this is one month ago in Hindi so tells
me Google Translate I don't actually
read Andy but it if you can get that
humanized thing for humans and we don't
speak English which is kind of nice and
then third derivative of day time I want
to talk about is called pendulum which
is a very ambitious extension it not
only expand extends day time but there
is an extension of the time class and
extension of the day class and of T Z
info and time Delta it is so is only
this is the only expansion package that
that provides all of these types not
just a date/time type it only supports
localized times which i think is a
feature not a bug it doesn't let you use
naive date times and because it it
doesn't actually wrap the types in the
day time package its subclasses then
that means its types are
drop-in replacements for other api's
that may require a day time or a date or
a time type so that's a that's a very
handy feature as well it uses time zone
data from a yet another Python package
called tight easy data which only
includes the data this has its own
implementation of reading reading the
time zone files which is some weird
binary format which you don't want
implementers so pendulum has smart
parsing you can basically hand it like
like like a utila you can hand it some
random time stamp string that you pulled
off the internet and some CSV file and
it can figure out how to parse it for
you it has lots of formatting options it
has it supports the percent style ones
as well as the Jodha style YY YY mmdd
style it has about 50 languages this is
what dates look like in Turkish I think
and as lots a ton of convenience method
you can say convert this to find the
start of the century containing the
state or the end of the you can find me
find me last Wednesday find me the end
of the hour you can add our a Zed
minutes and so this one I think is the
most feature complete of all of them and
the API in my opinion at least is pretty
nicely designed but this is PI data so
one-time value is clearly not enough
everyone here probably has a million of
them at a time minimum that they need to
work with we want to store data sets
containing times convening dates content
containing times of days so let's
consider the options and there are
honestly are not that many if you use
numpy you are probably familiar with
date times 64 which is a d type that
numpy or provides there's actually a
family of D types is parameterised by a
unit which is I think unique in non
punchy types it has the advantage of
storing times and dates very efficiently
as a disadvantage that they're basically
no operations you can apply to them you
can put a time in and you can get it out
and you can convert it to other time
units that's about it you can go from
seconds to microseconds days to
nanoseconds but that's it that's
basically it and I think you can compare
them which ones larger than the other so
here's an example of that I took
sometimes and I told it D time date/time
64 nanoseconds and again array of
nanoseconds and this
tastic because they take up eight bytes
each instead of 400 bytes or whatever a
big object takes so you have a million
of them you care
however pandas now pandas is probably
what most people use for data science
it's backed by numpy arrays so pan this
does use date/time 64 under the hood but
pandas goes through great lengths to
paper over the future gaps in num PI's
date/time 64 it's really a heroic effort
so it uses a time 64 under the hood but
one of the things that does is it adds
localization so if you have a pandas
date time index sorry it's kind of hard
to format code to fit on a in a big font
on the screen but if you have a pan as
date time index you can call cheesy
localize on it and give it a time zone
string and you'll see pandas now has
crayon the time zone into the detail
which numpy doesn't know anything about
that this is a panda sysm but it's super
useful
so date/time indexes then have a bunch
of time specific methods TZ I see people
yawning I told you this would be boring
TZ convert for instance or which will
convert from one time zone to another
this is a kind of thing it's super
boring until you need to do it and then
you're like holy cow how do I do this
right so it's really good that pandas
has worked so hard to add this stuff if
you have a time valued series so we're
not not the index but the actual values
are times the the time methods are not
directly on the series object there's
this DTE proxy object that kind of
collects them together so you do series
dot DT dot easy convert or TZ localize
or just hour if you want to get the
hours out and that's how you work with
time valued series or columns and data
frames one other thing that pandas does
to take heroic efforts to make your
lives better is it provides this
timestamp class for single values so if
you have a numpy at the time 64 array
and you fish one value out you get back
at date/time 64 scaler which has as many
operations as the array does namely
nothing but time but pandas instead
gives you this timestamp object which
derives from day time but also does a
bunch of things first of it patches it
so that it has nanosecond resolution
instead of microsecond resolution which
is super useful and then it tosses in
all of these other
specific methods that are available in
this series and on the date/time index
so if you if you take this daytime 64
this is not daytime 64 column and fish a
value out you get back there's a weird
timestamp class that's pandas trying to
be helpful if you go to the underlying
umpire and get a value out numpy is not
going to help so those are the packages
I want to talk about we're running out
of time but I want to talk briefly about
performance I don't have time to present
benchmark results here if you go in the
github repo some of the results are
there you can obviously run your own the
usual caveats about micro benchmarking
interpretation apply here but I just
want to give you a general sense for for
our performance of these things as I
mentioned before the day time package is
surprisingly efficient a lot of
operations run in under a microsecond on
my laptop
compared to that you day time provides a
few things that are about the same speed
or faster but probably is not going to
be a big deal for most people
numpy is date/time 64 and panda's
timestamp operations are generally a
little bit slower for scalar objects but
in an array or in a series or in a data
frame they're quite fast
DeLorean Aaron pendulum add a lot of
overhead to time so if you care about
performance these are probably not for
you
DeLorean particularly is kind of super
slow and then among the time zone
library is PI TZ seems to perform faster
than gates without TZ so if you have a
choice probably ITC is the way to go
finally round up there's some more stuff
again in the write up there's a future
matrix you can see all the stuff in a
grid but my recommendations are for ease
of use if you're working with individual
x dates or whatever pendulum i think is
the best choice it has a ton of features
the API is clear the documentation is
good in contrast to DeLorean and to
arrow it provides day time date types
time types and so forth and as I
mentioned before it's classes are
subclasses of the standard module ones
so they're more compatible with other
packages you may need to use I would say
arrow is a solid second choice if you
don't care about date handling because
it doesn't provide a date type DeLorean
I
really recommend I think it's someone
older and hasn't been development if you
care about performance for individual
values stick with daytime the built-in
daytime and used by TZ for timezone data
the feature set is somewhat sparse but
as I presented you can augment it
somewhat with some additional
third-party modules and for large data
sets I can't really implement I can't
really recommend numpy unless you are
fully committed to numpy as it is it'll
store your day times but that's about it
if you need any other operations go
appends and finally my last bit of
advice is that even if you are using
pandas primarily I recommend you learn
how to use the standard library daytime
a-class it is the sort of lingua franca
of times and dates in pythons so a lot
of api's which are not data science
oriented may force you to use it so you
should probably learn how to use it
that's it thank you so questions
it's actually better than that Olsen
database are not snapshots of current
time zone rules they complete they have
complete time histories since actually
pre-atomic loft days of so like for
instance it has a notion of what the
average u.s. Eastern time was in the
year 1900 it actually knows the time
history and some prediction of the Ford
future of time zones as government's
provide them so remember before I said
you have to use this TZ localize to
convert a naive day time to a localized
day time what that does is it actually
looks at the date time and figures out
what time that the time is looking for
and uses that to find the right point in
that time zones history and provide the
right offset based on that so it's done
for you
those guys are really like dedicated the
the data set behind this is crazy
detailed and there's lots of weird
geopolitical stuff going on under the
hood more questions
I had us at sort of about that with a
certain pandas maintainer who's in that
corner of the room we can chat with him
afterwards I think I can't speak to that
anything else I know it's fast off so
look at the write-up it's kind of easier
to read actually that's elicits me
blather on so thanks very much
[Applause]